Sure. My name is Carmen Clelland and I do go by nickname of Skip,
so that's fine for Skip.
I started my career within the India Health Service and
spent 20 plus years within clinical functions,
with India Health Service, and then also
administrative services within the India Health Service.
Later, past three years,
I've been working at the CDC.
During this period of time though,
I've always had an interest in medication adherence,
the issues of medication here,
and what it means to a patient level, provider level,
public level as far as,
how can we identify ways to help provide solutions to
medication adherence and why is
such an important issue to address overall as a public health issue?
Sure. The apps that we we're looking at because of
the overall greater focus on public health medication adherence.
Now, when I talk about that,
what I'm trying to explore is,
how can we use public health data along, or just regular,
even Big Data, along with the information that we would get from potentially,
a patient medical record through an EHR,
an aggregate data form for physicians,
for pharmacists, for patients,
for public health professionals,
in order to drive a change in dynamic,
and how people view medication adherence?
The goal was as if we were to identify how medication adherence is within a county,
or a census tract,
or in a case,
one of the areas that we were thinking of was a tribal tract,
and be able to say,
in this part of the city,
or this part of the reservation,
or this part in rural America,
or this part in a county,
that you know that your adherence rate on a certain medication is 60%.
Well, how can we identify that in order to
drive medication prescribing patterns, maybe drive education,
maybe drive other factors that might be involved,
even to planning of cities,
or planning of rural areas,
and making sure that we address it on a more public health role issue,
looking at population health,
then being able to help improve that patient's ability,
to have all the things they need in order to have better medication adherence practices.
That was the goal of this and it sounds kind of lofty.
One of the things I worked with the two teams,
and it's interesting because the interaction between the two teams was different too.
One was very engaged,
the other team was slightly engaged,
although they didn't need that subject matter expertise,
being a clinical pharmacist all those years,
I was able to provide that to that team with some information,
and then follow up and so I met with them maybe just a couple of times.
The other team though was more engaged,
they wanted to have some more input about what medication here it was,
why was it this issue?
Why did they think that FHIR technology
and being able to develop strategies to help support that technology in use.
A population health data could help solve this issue.
I went through with that team,
my thinking on this,
and why I thought this could be a way to look at it.
They were very much engaged,
and ended up developing
a nice framework concept that would lead to a proof of concept at some point,
in order to say, "Can we develop these applications using FHIR Technology,
Big Data, insurance claim information potentially Medicare claim, Medicare claim data?
All those things that can be accessible,
and then using it to be able to use it as a population tool to help prescribers,
pharmacists, patients, and then public health professionals
that develop the right strategies to improve medication adherence."
Because, if we make just overall group strategy of doing medication adherence,
it may not apply to the person in inner city versus the person in the rural,
versus the person on a reservation,
versus the person living wherever they are,
and having better aggregate data in
those population areas that we want to really focus on,
will help drive better prescribing patterns from physicians,
better counseling from pharmacists,
better ability to take the medications from the patients,
and better public health campaigns from the public health practitioners.
That is the strategy on that.
The framework that the one team developed,
was called the Medication Adherence Support System Conceptual Architecture.
And what the goal of that,
was to look at it from that perspective,
of not only just always focusing on that patient perspective,
but looking to say,
"Who are all the people that need to interact with that?"
And then how does that interaction need to coordinate together,
to be able to drive the data into the interface,
and then being able to regurgitate it out in a way that is meaningful to that physician,
still meaningful to the patient,
meaningful to the pharmacist meaningful to all,
to the public health practitioner,
and supporting the overall goal of,
"I want that patient to be healthy,
I want to be able to take the medication and we know if they take their medication,
chances are they will have mostly success with whatever chronic disease,
or other issues that they're working to deal with."
And so, that was how that architecture was set up.
As you look at the architecture that they developed,
it really is strategic in nature,
where you can actually focus on various elements of this concept architecture,
and continue to develop,
we may be one module over here,
and another module later,
in order to some point,
in five years maybe,
have the full architecture put together,
that would then you could go out and use to be able to help
drive public health medication adherence,
and then eventually, affecting as a population strategy.
That's how the architecture was developed and it's very detailed
in how they came up with that conceptual architecture.
What the team did,
that did the conceptual architecture,
they also worked on initial component of an app,
which is the Patient Facing App.
And probably for most of the apps that we see,
that's probably the easiest because it just requires patient data input,
as far as, "Did they take the medication?
What time of day did they take it?," those types of things.
There's a multitude of those out on the market.
That was the first strategy that both teams actually
ended up creating examples of their apps,
and doing that, and what that would look like.
Both of them had some good components to it with regards to,
when they miss doses, what was that,
or what was the cause of missed doses?
One of the things that I cautioned them on that is,
when you're talking about the patients,
there's this whole fatigue issue
of being overwhelmed by always having to put stuff into a program,
or having to hit a buzzer or something to that,
where eventually you start phasing it out,
and it just becomes background noise.
And how do we use that strategy in the future to help prevent these things?
Where you get your key information into those patients facing apps,
and then being able to retrieve that out at the other end,
so that way, the physicians,
and the pharmacists, and the public health people,
can have access to that information,
clean of course, so that way it doesn't identify patients at a patient level,
but enough, where they can say,
"In this urban area,
in Atlanta, medications in ward
six is only taking hypertensive medications 40% of the time.
Why is in Ward 6 that is creating this as an overall thing?"
That way we would want to explore and then you'd be able to say,
"Now I can do it, because I have the data.
I can go to my city planner,
I can go to the pharmacist,
I can go detail physicians,
and let them know this is a strategy that they can do."
And so that's how the architecture was set up to do,
to be able to support that,
and make it into something that's workable,
usable, and eventually in the end,
be something that can make an impact.
I think the next step,
it needs to go in a couple of different phases.
Clearly, there's work done initially on the patient phase,
but it's not complete as the way these were.
I can't remember how many weeks the sessions were
so they had limit time with their team together.
There's still need to work on that patient app.
There needs to be development on how to build in the FHIR Technology,
bringing in the FHIR Technology,
along with Big Data to incorporate,
so you can start seeing conceptually,
how Big Data impacts decision-making at a county, census tract,
tribal tract, other population modalities of how you to
identify groups of people and then bring that into an application.
Because I think that's when you'll start seeing how you can drive this information.
There's plenty of patient apps out
there that you might be able to get some information from,
and I'm sure there's a lot of people,
skilled and looking at it from that perspective since that's
the most common way people would use to help say,
"I can help improve adherence."
But then driving in this other point,
so I think the next phase for me,
and what we're looking at with this,
is to drive that population health data
gathering along with access to some sort of patient records system,
that includes claims data, those types of things.
That would be able to make this a more comprehensive look at medication adherence.
Then with that, look at that population health part of it,
and then saying, "How can we affect health equity because of what we're using?"
Now with data making decisions versus
the anecdotal information you tend to get from patients, "I'll take this",
or the late dose,
"I'm going to start taking this a week for my doctor's appointments,
so that way doesn't look like I'm not," or other things.
And it's not necessarily all the patients fault,
it's just the way our system is set up,
to not necessarily look at medication adherence as an issue,
it's more or less,
the chronic disease issue.
But if you're spending hundreds of billions dollars a year on medications,
and there's a lot of that being wasted,
then we're looking at also something that can have
an impact on our health care of our system overall,
as well as our public health systems overall too.
So that's the next strategy on this. Thank you.